وبما اننا نتحدث عن الازياء اليمنيه
سنحتفي معها بهذه الازياء وبتنوعها الزي
العدني وهو الثوب الذي تلبسه النساء في
منطقه عدن وما حولها ويتميز بالوانه
المختلفه وبلمسات ذهبيه اللون الزي
الصنعاني وهو الزي الذي تلبسه النساء في
صنعاء وضواحيها ويتكون من فستان اسمه
الزنه وعليه العصبه او المصعر والتي توضع
على الراس وهو مزين بالحلي الفضيه ويسمى
الرش الزي التعزيه يعود واصله ازاي
التعديل الدوره الحميريه يتكون الزيت من
الثوب وهو المكون الرئيسي ويطلق عليه
القميص بالاضافه الى السروال والمصار
والمجرمه
الزي اليافعي يعود لمنطقه يافا اليمنيه
القريبه من لحج ويعد احد اجمل الازياء
النسائيه اليمنيه حيث يجمع بين البساطه في
الزرقشه والزينه والالوان الجميله
والحزام المذهب او الفضي الذي يحيط الخصر
مالحه عن الثوب الكثير من الالق والجمال